la luce da dove viene la luce tutta la
luce che abbiamo attorno a noi anche
quella che viene da questi oggetti
illuminati viene dal cielo in un modo
dell'altro ci ha raggiunto magari il
tempo fa dal cielo la luce viene
solamente dal cosmo la quale cosmo da
quello che ci circonda
da questo cielo che non possiamo vedere
da questa città
bergamo non può vedere questo cielo
questo ce lo si vede solamente in africa
si vede quando è buio quando la città
non illumina appunto il cielo di notte
se vi capita di andare nel sud del mondo
vedete questo cielo bene immaginiamoci
di essere qualche tempo fa a 2 milioni e
mezzo di anni fa ci sarà postato un
primo momento in cui un ominide nella
fase evolutiva abbia alzato gli occhi da
terra e abbia realizzato che cosa aveva
sopra la sua testa
immaginatevi quell'istante un istante
importante della nostra storia che va
remota nei tempi lontanissimi bene da
quando a quel momento in poi l'uomo ha
sempre avuto con sé la sua cultura
la coscienza dell'universo e della luce
che ci arriva dal cielo
facciamo un grande salto questo profilo
lo conoscete benissimo è il profilo di
stonehenge code stonehenge è una
realizzazione di un popolo primitivo
siamo a 4.500 anni fa quindi
praticamente siamo prima della storia è
uno degli esempi di come lo studio
l'osservazione del cielo abbia plasmato
la cultura dell'umanità
per fare questo particolare sistema di
costruttivo quella popolazione antica ha
fatto uno sforzo immenso ha portato dei
massi pesantissimi da decine forse
centinaia di chilometri di distanza per
strutturarli una struttura circolare di
grandissima dimensione per quale motivo
per traguardare
le stelle per vedere le moto dei pianeti
per capire quando seminare quando
raccogliere per fare dei miti dei diriti
legati alle mitologie legate appunto
alle informazioni che venivano dal cielo
il cielo ha sempre plasmato la cultura
maya egizia e tutta la storia
dell'umanità e secondo questo esempio
usando la tecnologia le caratteristiche
più avanzate dell'epoca
facciamo un altro salto facevano stato
di 2300 anni
siamo nel mediterraneo una nave greco
romana trasporto del materiale tra la
grecia e l'italia e affonda davanti
all'isola di kit era unito del pollo del
peloponneso nel 1906 renzo il secolo
scorso
questo relitto viene trovato e
raccogliendo il materiale trovato nel
relitto nella stiva di una nave vecchia
2.200 anni a quel punto a parte le
solite anfore si trovano delle strutture
come questa delle specie di rum di
rotelle completamente coperti di calcare
che vengono portate al museo di atene e
lasciati lì per 60 anni non si sa cosa
fossero
sessant'anni dopo fanno le radiografie
con i raggi ics e scoprono all'interno
di queste rotelle degli ingranaggi
sottilissimi tipo di orologi del
seicento ma siamo a 200 avanti cristo
queste una sorta di astrolabio un
sistema che permetteva ai potenti di
allora di calcolarsi il moto dei pianeti
soprattutto le eclissi di sole di luna
immaginatevi cosa vuol dire per un
generale o per un politico sapere quando
il sole sta per scomparire quando la
luna sta per essere oscurata bene una
tecnologia incredibilmente sofisticata
cicero non ci racconta c'era un tool di
queste macchine a quel tempo disponibile
nel nell'allora civiltà greco romana una
l'abbiamo ritrovata in fondo al mare
una fortuna straordinaria un altro
esempio di come la tecnologia la più
sofisticata stata messa a disposizione
per che cosa studiare prevedere capire
il cielo facciamo un altro salto
questo è una patina dell'arma gesto lama
gesto era una sorta di treccani
di vincere di abilità annica in cui era
raccolta tutta l'informazione nota
l'umanità nel 1000 anni sono intercorsi
tra la fine dell'impero romano la metà
del 1100 millennio bene come potete
vedere dalle questioni da questa
immagine la terra è perfettamente
formata
ciao a tutti i continenti america del
nord america del sud
perfino l'australia qual è il problema è
al centro del mondo
tutte quante le sfere celesti la
circondano
il quella che trasporta al sole quella
trasporta la luna i vari pianeti via via
fino alla sfera che porta le stelle
fisse infatti siamo nel 1550 l'america
scoperta da colombo nel 1492
ma non c'è ancora la comprensione di
dov'è questo pianeta all'interno
dell'universo infatti occorre aspettare
il 1609 quando galileo con questo
piccolo cannocchiale che oggi e comprate
dalla leader per 50 euro
capi che c'erano i satelliti che
giravano intorno a un pianeta che era
giove e che stavano perforando stavano
rovinando stavano distruggendo l'armonia
delle sfere celesti e finalmente la
terra trovò il suo posto l'universo non
era che il sole di grave intorno alla
terra ma la terra attorno al sole
bene il cannocchiale la tecnologia del
momento
naturalmente lo zucchero tecnologico ha
portato a dei progressi straordinari
questo è un cannocchiale del secolo
scorso il cannocchiale con voi fabol
guardò a lungo la nostra galassia prese
delle immagini del nostro insieme di
stelle che si pensava allora che fosse
tutto l'universo e studiando alcune
piccole stelle un po sfocate capi da una
notte all'altra che erano altre galassie
molto molto lontane da un notte
all'altro universo si espanse di un
fattore più di mille ed allora abbiamo
continuato espanderlo fino ad arrivare
praticamente alle sue origini
questo con un telescopio chiaramente
molto più potente di quello di ca di
galileo
oggi abbiamo nello spazio il telescopio
dei telescopi il telescopio di hubble
che guarda
l'universo usando le condizioni
straordinariamente favorevoli di potere
fare osservazioni dallo spazio
e questa immagine che vedete sulla
destra è una capocchia di spillo del
cosmo sulla nostra testa ingrandita e
una quantità enorme di volte da hubble e
vediamo le prime galassie le prime
protostelle vediamo universo di miliardi
e miliardi di anni fa dicevo che la
tecnologia è fondamentale per capire
l'universo attorno a noi
ma vedrete come è sorprendente la
velocità con cui la tecnologia evoluta
in quest'ultimo secolo il secolo che è
passato ha fatto per ci ha permesso di
fare dei progressi molto più grandi che
i millenni e in milioni di anni che ci
hanno anticipato vedete questa immagine
siamo la cappella degli scrovegni e
vediamo come giotto nel 1301 dipingesse
una bellissima serie di pitture fra cui
la natività e si può apprezzare la
bellezza di questa pittura perché
vediamo
scusate vediamo la forma
vediamo le immagini delle persone gli
animali una prospettiva della capanna ma
sopra la capanna vediamo una brutta
stella cometa una sorta di pallottola
rossastra e ci domandiamo come mai un
grande pittore come giotto avesse
disegnato una stella cometa così brutta
perché l'aveva vista nel cielo perché
vedeva in quell'istante quella stella
passare sulla sua testa e la cometa di
halley che passano i 76 anni e nel 1301
passava sulla testa di questo pittore
che l'accoppiata fedelmente infatti
queste foto del 1910 le prime foto di
questa cometa ci mostrano una struttura
del tutto analoga a quella che giotto
dipingeva nel 1300 e nel 1986 76 anni
dopo
l'uomo era in grado di fare i suoi
satelliti artificiali il suo ri suoi
robot telecomandati che sono andati
letteralmente a pizzicare la coda della
cometa di giotto per vedere com'è fatta
600 anni e passare dall occhio alla
fotografia 76 anni per passare la
fotografia
alla capacità di raggiungere la stella
con la cometa di halley tecnologia
tecnologie a questi signori sono penzias
e wilson due ingegneri che da di famosi
perché hanno sostanzialmente pubblicato
un articolo dicendo abbiamo cercato di
fare un segno uno strumento elettronico
di bassissimo rumore ambientale che
praticamente dovesse essere misurare ho
nessun tipo di rumore e sentiamo un
rumore continuo assordante che viene da
tutte le parti l'universo
questo è uno loro orecchio che
un'antenna una sorta di a grande antenna
radio che gli ha permesso di capire che
il loro rumore veniva dappertutto non
sapevano che cosa avevano trovato un
pubblicato questo risultato e poche
settimane dopo altri hanno interpretato
che loro stavano ascoltando l'eco del
big bang e hanno avuto il premio nobel
per questo un rumore che di fatto è
l'eco della grande esplosione iniziale
oggi questo tipo di studi si fanno con
strumenti molto più potenti questo
pallone stratosferico ha studiato
quell'eco del big bang capendo che è
strutturato in modo molto particolare
se voi mettete gli occhiali per guardare
il big bang sono una specie di google
gli occhiali google un po particolari
che fanno gli scienziati che studiano
queste cose e uscite fuori guardare il
cielo vedreste butterato come il
morbillo col morbillo e il dettaglio
dell'esplosione legata al big bang visto
300.000 anni dopo e forse voi avete
visto un'immagine come questo le prime
pagine dei principali quotidiani un
satellite chiamato planck ha completato
questa immagine del cielo col morbillo
col morbillo del big bang è un ciro
appunto che si è rivelato 280 mila anni
300.000 anni dopo il big bang ma
recentemente sui giornali
avete sentito questa cosa incredibile
uno strumento posto al polo sud ha fatto
ancora di più ha trovato in questa
immagine di 300.000 anni una traccia di
qualche cosa che è successo un
miliardesimo di secondo dopo
l'esplosione iniziale questi cerchi
nella luce polarizzata nel cielo ci
stanno raccontando cosa è successo
proprio all'inizio
i tempi tecnologia ma che cosa è
successo negli ultimi 50 anni una
grandissima rivoluzione abbiamo imparato
a guardare i colori dell'universo che
non sono visibili all'occhio umano e
soprattutto non sono visibili dalla
terra l'universo che ha visto galileo
hubble con i suoi telefoni telescopi ci
manda quella luce che passa
nell'atmosfera questa luce una luce
visibile che attraversa bene l'aria le
onde radio visto da da penzias e wilson
sono come dei telefonini passano bene
attraverso l'aria sono moltissime altre
onde che non riescono a passare
attraverso l'aria per vedere le quali
dobbiamo uscire letteralmente uscire
dall'atmosfera e in questi ultimi 50
anni siamo riusciti a fare questo
sistematicamente e siamo riusciti a dire
tutti i colori dell'universo altrimenti
invisibile per esempio questa immagine
che voi vedete se andiamo sul visibile è
l'universo la via lattea che domina la
nostra il punto di vista diciamo visto
dalla terra vista con gli occhi del
primo ominide con gli occhi di galileo
con gli occhi di hubble nel visibile a
una certa struttura chiaramente non
riusciamo da tutta quanta ma queste
caratteristiche
se andiamo nell'infrarosso che una
frequenza che non passa attraverso
l'atmosfera vediamo una figura
completamente diverso se andiamo nelle
microonde son quelle del forno a
microonde che abbiamo in cucina di nuovo
cambia completamente se andiamo nel
radio che quello che si recedere anche
dalla terra con le misure per esempio di
pensi a seguire sono cambio di nuovo
delle grandi insiemi di gas freddo che
appaiono e mettere quel tipo di luce
radio
se andiamo nell'ultravioletto che è un
colore che non passa facilmente
l'atmosfera nascono tutta una serie di
stelle altrimenti invisibili nel
visibile nei raggi ics cambia di nuovo
il nostro universo appare competente
diverso con delle sorgenti caldissime
per andare a fine ai raggi gamma che
sono quelle delle esplosioni nucleari
esistono degli oggetti
esplodono tipo nucleare senza sosta da
milioni e milioni di anni questo
l'universo che oggi noi abbiamo davanti
agli occhi un universo pieno di colori
che 50 anni fa non conoscevamo
questa è la parte diverso invisibile che
è diventato visibile che si è di sfilato
negli ultimi 50 anni grazie al lavoro di
persone come riccardo giacconi un
italiano ha avuto il nobel nel 2002
perché ha scoperto l'universo fatto di
sorgenti di raggi ics nessuno ci credeva
non fare questo esperimento lui
insistette cocciutamente andò in america
costruire questo satellite lo mise in
orbita e vide le prime sorgenti di raggi
ics
eppure questo satellite che si chiama
fermi in onore del nostro grande fisico
degli anni 40 agli anni 50 che
letteralmente osserva l'universo
caldissimo in continua esplosione
nucleare oppure questi strumenti ancora
più moderni che si chiamano strumenti a
lucia cernko che guardano della luce di
un colore così estremo che non siamo
nemmeno in grado di produrla nei nostri
laboratori e un'energia spaventosamente
alta che viene prodotta in alcuni casi
da delle sorgenti di dei mostri di
energia che sono in alcuni porti parti
del nostro universo
bene questo spiega un pochettino per chi
in orbita abbiamo tanti satelliti
ciascuno sono occhi che guardano in
colori diversi che guardano a distanze
diverse che guardano vicino o così
lontano da toccare i bordi dell'universo
visibile da rinviare fino a toccare il
big bang e oggi abbiamo quindi queste
meravigliose immagini della via lattea
ma anche dell'universo in tutti i colori
possibili e immaginabili
questo il nostro universo diventato
visibile negli ultimi 60 anni prima il
90 per cento era completamente
irraggiungibile
abbiamo finito abbiamo raggiunto il
compimento della scienza abbiamo
raggiunto i limiti delle osservabile no
non conosciamo ancora davvero quello che
è il vero universo oscuro
c'è un universo che è talmente oscuro
che non riesce neanche ad emettere la
luce non solamente la luce che mette non
passa l'atmosfera c'è un universo che è
sostanzialmente invisibile a qualsiasi
forma di luce e quindi abbiamo imparato
recentemente negli ultimi 50 anni
tante cose dante dante l'universo
sappiamo che piatto omogeneo isotropo è
composto da radiazione da materia
protoni da neutroni come noi ma sappiamo
che solamente è il 4 per cento del
totale
esiste una componente che si chiama
materia oscura che sappiamo essere il
ventre per cento in sei volte più
abbondante della materia normale ed è in
questa stanza e ha tra chi attraversa ma
non riusciamo a vederla
non solo abbiamo in ben capito che c'è
un altro 73 per cento che energia
nascosta nel vuoto di cui non sappiamo
assolutamente niente se non che esiste e
tra le altre cose
tanti materia primordiale che era
presente al big bang se n'è andata e non
sappiamo che fine ha fatto per cui
abbiamo imparato a guardare tutti i
colori dell'universo
ma mentre facevamo questo abbiamo
scoperto che c'è un 95 per cento di
universo che è letteralmente presente ma
invisibile con tutte le tecniche che noi
abbiamo potuto inventare in questi
ultimi 50 anni per cui sappiamo di non
sapere non siamo mai stati così
ignoranti in modo cosciente
relativamente alla natura quindi dopo un
secolo di straordinaria crescita dopo
una tecnologia che è letteralmente
esplosa ci ha aperto la tutti i colori
l'universo siamo arrivati a un nuovo
bordo un nuovo confine sappiamo che il
95 per cento di ciò che ci circonda deve
essere ancora scoperto e quindi siamo
alle soglie di un nuovo millennio in cui
ci rimane da scoprire
la maggior parte delle cose che ci
circondano e quindi il mio pensiero per
questa chiacchierata di te dx
ahahah sappiamo che il 95 per cento
dell'universo è assolutamente invisibile
si cercano idee per capire di cosa stia
fatto grazie